but the world isn't necessarily marching
in towards progress that were not
necessarily moving in a utopian sort of
direction you look at the the inequality
in our society you you look at all these
problems and you have to say that
something has gone wrong in this country
at in an institutional sort of way and
that that all these big changes that
were meant to bring progress aren't
necessarily bringing progress and we're
about to take even bigger leaps forward
into the future and we're in in ways in
which we can't understand so when
Zuckerberg talks about telepathy as the
technology we could laugh at him we
could say maybe this guy doesn't know
what he's talking about but he's hired
the best scientists in the world to
develop this and maybe there is
something there and maybe these the
sci-fi future is really just a few steps
ahead of us and so the core question
really is what what do we want human
beings to be how do we want to do we
need to think about the future in a much
more intentional sort of way especially
since we don't know what's going to
happen to the future of work we know
that automation is happening extremely
quickly we look at Amazon buying Whole
Foods and you can say that the grocery
store as we know it is probably not
going to exist in a couple years and
that that they'll be drones and and and
there probably won't be cashiers
and that's just a small taste of what
automation could potentially do to us
and none of this is mono causal there
are all sorts of things that are
happening in our world we live in a
globalized world the the the the the
political problems and social problems
that we face in this country
have ample ample causes but this is
really just something where the change
has happened it that we can see the rise
of these corporations and we can start
to think about the choices that we make
not just in our own lives but as a
society and rather than just drift off
into a future we should be we should be
as thoughtful about it as
of all we should be skeptical when
skepticism is merited and we should
remember that even if it's hard to see
the ways in which we have human agency
we still have human agency and I will
add to that that's what I think is
beautiful and critical about this book
and why everyone should read it and
everyone will be talking about it is
because it just you can't unless you're
aware of the air that you're breathing
and sort of like the life that you're
living and and what's behind it and
what's in it you can't change it so so
at the very least read it to understand
the ideology behind everything that
you're you're doing and thinking I think
we'll end it there
thank you guys so much for coming
[Applause]
book TV is on Twitter and Facebook and
we want to hear from you tweet us
twitter.com slash book TV or post a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV
good evening everyone
when thanks for joining us tonight my
name is Maddy Walters and on behalf of
the Harvard bookstore and our co-sponsor
this evening the Nieman Foundation I'm
very pleased to welcome you to this
evening's event with Andrea Pitzer
presenting her new book one long night
we're pleased to have c-span's book TV
here taping to bait today's event when
asking questions in the Q&A please know
that you'll be recorded and please wait
a moment for the microphone to come over
to you before asking your question here
at the Harvard bookstore we're gearing
up for a fall season absolutely packed
with fantastic author events including
talks of Patti Smith Patti Smith
Katherine psychic sorry mm EJ Dionne jr.
and Masha Gessen for details and
information on these and are many other
upcoming events visit our events
calendar at Harvard home slash events
and sign up for our weekly email
newsletter or you can pick up one here
tonight's talk will conclude with some
time for your questions after which
we'll have a book signing right here at
this table
the signing line will form through the
doorway to my left and copies of the
book are sold at the register in the
other room tonight's featured title is
20% off so this evening
this event booked a discount as part of
how we say thanks for buying books here
at the Harvard bookstore your purchases
support this author series and ensure
the future of an independent bookstore
so thank you and finally just a quick
reminder to silence your cellphone's for
the talk and now I'm very pleased to
introduce tonight's speaker andrea
Pitzer is a journalist whose previous
work has appeared in publications such
as McSweeney's fox slate and lanthum
scored early she is the author of the
secret history of Vladimir Nabokov and
the founder of the Neiman's story board
which is the narrative nonfiction site
of the Nieman Foundation the story board
highlights and explores the future of
exceptional journalism and nonfiction
storytelling long before she gave in
turn
national lectures on narrative
journalism she was a portrait painter a
French translator and a record store
manager backgrounds that have perhaps
influenced her desire to uncover
forgotten history tonight she's
presenting her new book one long night a
global history of concentration camps
Kirkus Reviews calls it a potent
powerful history and deborah blum writes
that it is a fearless and elegant tale
of crew of human cruelty but also of
human courage told with such undaunted
moral clarity that the story serves to
remind us all that it is never too late
to stand up for what is right we are so
pleased to host its author here at the
Harvard bookstore tonight please join me
in welcoming Andrea Pitts sir thank you
for that lovely introduction and yes
from my record store past I do want to
come back and see Patti Smith if I could
get back together thank you all for
coming out tonight as well I would like
to start by reading you a little bit
from the book and I'll be reading a few
short passages and then explaining a
little between them and somehow
magically in about 25 minutes we're
gonna cover six continents and a century
of camps so hold on tight this is from
the first chapter and this is how
concentration camps came to be in the
world before Nazi extermination
factories arose in Europe before the
first prisoner entered the Soviet gulag
before the 20th century had even begun
concentration camps found their first
home in the cities and towns of Cuba the
modern experiment in preemptively
detaining groups of civilians without
trial was launched by two generals one
who refused to bring camps into the
world and another who did not in 1895
Cuban rebels had declared independence
from Spain while the government while
the government in Madrid collapsed in
the face of anxiety over yet another war
rebels spent the spring harassing
Spanish forces occasionally seizing
rifles bullets and food
representatives of the Cuban quinta had
lived in exile in America for years
organizing their resistance raising
money and ginning up sympathy stateside
choosing their moment rebel leaders and
exile returned to the island to fight
the first general Spain sent to lead the
campaign Arsenio Martinez composts knew
Cuba well he had fought for five years
in the last Spanish war their concluding
a piece as governor that sparked the
eventual abolition of slavery on the
island he had since commanded Spanish
forces in Mexico and Morocco led a coup
that restored the monarchy in Spain and
survived an assassination attempt by the
time he returned to Cuba he was 53 years
old around man with a VanDyke beard gone
quite a mixture of progressive ideals
and atavistic honor known for the
judicious use of both warfare and
negotiation but during Martinez composts
first months back on the ground
nature appeared to favor the rebels Cuba
in high summer was a heat stroke ridden
swamp of malaria and yellow fever some
locals had immunity through prior
exposure but few Spaniards did illness
decimated imperial forces just as
profoundly as any rebel stealth attack
on the insurgent side dynamite and
ambush proved effective tools for
stalling the forward progress of Spanish
troops or stealing their supplies a
small number of snipers even with
outdated weapons could instill terror in
a whole column of troops able to
disappear into the countryside at will
the rebels could pick and choose their
encounters leaving Spanish forces
plotting how to draw them into
traditional battle the insurgents spent
their first months making strategic
raids or capturing undefended towns that
July Martinez Campos went into the field
to provoke a decisive fight only to see
his troops forced to flee the field by
superior rebel tactics even given the
insurgents intelligence networks it was
a staggering humiliation for Spain faced
with escalating measures on the part of
the rebels and pressured by a new
government overseas less inclined toward
concession
Martina's Campos began to consider
desperate means to end the uprising days
later he wrote the Spanish Prime
Minister giving a stark assessment of
the challenges facing his troops as for
what could be done in the future to
improve Spain's position he explained
that it would be possible to
reconsecrate hundreds of thousands of
rural Cubans into Spanish held towns
behind trenches and barbed wire but he
would need significant forces to hold
them there he felt certain that emptying
the countryside to isolate insurgents
would be effective but the price to be
paid and misery and hunger would be
horrible history is full of moments in
which hindsight provides the only clear
view this is not one of them during the
final months before a concentration
became official policy as his own troops
and the rebels both adopted harsher
tactics Martinez Campos explained to the
spanish prime minister that he had
already authorized shooting armed rebel
commanders captured in battle and those
caught setting fires to homes and crops
though Martinez Campos found Cubans
dangerous and unconventional fighters he
described how they had nursed Spanish
wounded who fell into their hands and
returned prisoners of war unharmed he
could not he telegraphed to Spain raised
the stakes in brutality against an
opponent he felt to be honorable after
years of fighting the rebels in multiple
campaigns captain general Arsenio marked
as Martinez Campos offered to surrender
his Imperial post governing the island
rather than embark on a policy of
deliberate atrocity the man who thought
concentration camps the only road to
victory refused to embrace them Martinez
Campos could hardly have imagined the
gas chambers and the killing fields that
would bloom in the debris of the Cuban
experiment yet he understood the
suffering inherent in mass executions
and clearing the countryside of
inhabitants
I cannot he wrote as the representative
of a civilized nation be the first to
give the example of cruelty and
intransigence so Martinez Campos was
recalled a man whose nickname was the
butcher was sent in his
and the first concentration camps came
into the world in the United States
there was a lot of coverage of this and
there were pictures of starving dying
children millions of tons of aid were
sent by rail and then by boat to Cuba to
help the starving by concentrators and
this was a key factor in triggering
after the mains explosion the u.s. entry
into the spanish-american war America
landed in 1898 at Guantanamo Bay for
that invasion and of course we never
left and after defeating Spain handily
we inherited the Philippines where there
was also a rebellion underway and we
ended up using concentration camps
ourselves in that conflict a very short
number of years later in the same decade
the British in South Africa as southern
Africa at the time instituted camps
during the Boer War and in the same
period just a couple years after that
the Germans in the wake of a genocide
and their colony in South West Africa
set up camps for the nama and Herrero
people so in the space of a decade you
concentration camps come into the world
and are used as colonial outposts in a
number of locations after that they die
down for a while because the results are
so horrific that people want to distance
themselves from them but during World
War one this idea of preemptively
detaining civilians becomes too
convenient to resist so in a very short
number of years from the beginning of
World War one one to the end you have
concentration camps which is what they
were called at the time although now we
refer to them as internment camps
worldwide so they were literally on six
continents and from that you ended up
with a global bureaucracy of detention
the Red Cross was involved observing
sites inspecting them you could send
packages you could send letters there
were educational programs there were
libraries and all this served I think
very effectively to save some lives
because you didn't have the death tolls
you had in the early camps but it also
served to rehabilitate the idea of
concentration camps so by the end of
World War one
they aren't seen as a bad thing at all
they're seen as an unfortunate necessity
of the modern era
and because then this global bureaucracy
of detention has been set up after World
War one you see camps more morph into
other forms and take on local
characteristics so you get the gulag in
the Soviet Union which is very tied up
also with the history of forced labor in
Sarris Russia but becomes a new
phenomenon combined with this specific
idea of concentration camps and then of
course you have the Nazi camps you have
the American internment of
japanese-americans during World War two
each country that imposes them later
does it within the constraints of their
own institutions and so the outcomes are
quite different and they don't as much
cross-pollinate as they rise out of
these same roots the book itself though
is really told through the story of
prisoners so I want to make sure to give
you a little bit of a taste of that and
so this is a story of Christina's you
Alaska and her stories from Auschwitz
the larger group of women actually stood
here in the weeks that followed she
Volga received a first parcel from her
mother which she could hardly open for
weeping because she found roll-call
unbearable she began to compose poems in
her head a thing she had never done
before
yet setbacks occurred constant
continuously she watched as a new
acquaintance who had survived
interrogations and torture at Auschwitz
was taken away for good by the Gestapo
she and Zosia her friend had to flee
their barracks and hide to avoid being
chosen for service in a camp brothel
another prisoners ill-timed diarrhea
resulted in collective punishment of
kneeling in the mud which led to
widespread fever for the first time she
was separated from zojja
who fell ill after nearly succumbing to
work in the fields ja voll Co was
assigned to the camp office her
salvation came through the intervention
of his still human capo one who had
admired a poem she had written about
morning roll call assigned to process
new arrivals you volca learned to corral
and reassure them she could not bring
herself to hit prisoners with a stick
children came in with their mothers and
lined
with them at roll call only to be taken
away for D nationalization and
integration into German society a
Ukrainian woman gave up hope and made a
run at the barbed wire perimeter fence
knowing she would be shot one night
during a concert performed by prisoners
for administrators Capo's and guards
jhulka stopped in to watch a Jewish
violinist from Vienna play and conduct
just before the concert she had seen the
detainees of block 15 kneeling for
punishment she had watched the elegant
dark-haired Greek Jews sifting through
the kitchen garbage for bones to chew on
as the orchestra played Przewalski's
used the distraction of the performance
to slip into the typhus ridden hospital
ward and bring warm water to zojja
the surreal beauty and the horror of the
evening struck her but it was Scioscia
who stayed foremost in her mind zojja
who had endured alongside her since the
trip from pavia prison who had wondered
if they would roast together in hell
soon died anyway anything was possible
at Auschwitz and nothing made sense Jew
osika came down with typhus too and lay
unconscious for several days the
violinist from the performance swallowed
poison and killed herself a former
Soviet parachutist screamed in the night
and was tied to her bed Przewalski's
scabies began to itch and she clawed
herself yet after she was clandestinely
sent medicine by a male prisoner who had
kissed her during outdoor duties in her
first weeks at Auschwitz Jew Volga
recovered an intervention by the same
capo who had admired her writing helped
keep her once again from brutal outside
labor soon after her recovery a group of
French women were taken in trucks to
their deaths singing La Marseillaise a
patient in the hospital hid among
corpses in order to avoid being selected
for death with the sickest detainees
though she would surely be chosen in the
next round another prisoner wondered at
the effort everyone was making why do we
want so much to live after weeks in the
hospital
Yokosuka finally joined her new block
for roll call back in the tiny universe
of the camp she watched a prisoner
beaten for stealing potatoes an SS man
on a bicycle paused for a moment
to attack an old woman the crematorium
chimney spat fire into the sky the
Capo's were the same
the endless routines of the camp
remained but new prisoners lined up in
place of the dead and after that period
jhulka her offices moved to beer canal
which is the death camp at Auschwitz and
she becomes a witness to what's
happening there she herself was Jewish
and took on the identity of a Christian
pole in order to avoid being killed
herself and the world very much
understood although it took time and
still today of course we don't fully
understand what happened at Auschwitz
and near canal and the death camps but
it was understood right after the war
that it was a horrific thing that was a
new innovation in sort of modern horror
but the thing that happened also as a
result of that understanding was that
the bar was kind of reset for
concentration camps and anything less
than that somehow became not a
concentration camp it so changed the
whole way that these camps were viewed
that anything less than that still
seemed permissible so in a very short
period after the end of World War two
you have the rise you have several
communist revolutions some real some
imposed that happened in Eastern Europe
and in China and in some other locations
I don't go into all of it but in those
countries what you often end up with
sometimes because of Soviet advisors
sometimes through emulation is some form
of Soviet style gulags you have the idea
of reeducation through labor and death
tolls vary again depending on local
traditions but you have this whole kind
of camp rise that's based on that at the
same time from former allies you have a
kind of a reset to the very beginnings
of the camps the way they were in the
colonial era so you have the British in
Kenya you have the French in Algeria and
you have the French in the US and
Vietnam and in those cases it's much
more often mass civilian relocation and
fighting insurgencies and this was very
much there are these two kinds of camps
because of course the Cold War became
this binary that controlled a lot of how
geopolitics happen
and the camp's reflected that as well
and Makeda are so after the war there's
a kind of a shift and then from the 60s
into the 70s and the 80s in the book I
cover South America and you begin to see
not so much the colonial insurgencies
that you have with the British in Kenya
and the French in Algeria and such but
you have countries putting down elected
governments in their own nations and
using these tactics on what they call
terrorists and communists with varying
degrees of accuracy to preemptively
detain and often torture large groups of
people so in Santiago if you've ever
seen the pictures of people rounded up
into stadiums they did later shut those
down and some people went to
conventional camps but the new thing
that rose in this moment was this idea
of kind of atomizing detention and
clandestine detention so you had in the
basement of the escuela Mechanica and
the officer's casino there you had
thousands of people who were tortured
and only a few people survived but it
sort of worked as this camp but then
people were just killed when they were
finished with them so you have this
cross national because there's the thing
called Operation Condor where a lot of
these intelligence agencies collaborated
with each other
so for the first time you have these
cross national clandestine atomized
operations and I argue in the book that
that is then part of how we get to
Guantanamo as sort of the crown jewel of
a large network of detention that is
also atomized also clandestine also
involves torture and their sort of
routine application of torture the use
of government contractors are kind of
just-in-time
interrogation and I see this is all part
of a post-war sweep and so I don't think
want anima was just Guantanamo but in
the last chapter I talked about the
whole system but I focus on going on
about because that's what we still have
in place today even though it has a much
smaller number of detainees there there
are still some forever prisoners and the
working definition of concentration
camps in my book is mass detention of
civilians without trial or done
extraneously to the legal system in
at the time and I don't have time to go
in-depth into it right now but if you do
read in the chapter if you haven't
followed it the ways in which the people
who went to Guantanamo went there and
who they were as a group was very vague
and undefined so the mass of people that
were sent there one of the Bush
administration people within an
interview said it basically in summation
that if there's a captain in Afghanistan
and he's deciding whether because
there's overflow in the prisons they
need to be getting rid of some prisoners
Guantanamo opens is he gonna let this
guy go or is he gonna send them to
Guantanamo do you want to be the 23 year
old who maybe lets Osama bin Laden's
right-hand man go and I think the quote
that he said was boom he goes to
Guantanamo and that's how a lot of the
people but certainly not all of them but
a number of them came to be there so if
that's sort of the whole arc and I'm
happy to answer questions about any part
of it I want to read you I'm gonna spoil
it and read you the end of the book so
you sort of see a little bit how it
comes together without accountability no
dividing line can separate the past from
the future it is a hopeful sign that
years decades or even a century later
many governments have been called to
account for their actions along with the
Nuremberg trials and parallel
proceedings at other camps legal cases
restoring property and money to Jews and
other survivors of Nazi camps continue
today in this century Germany has
apologized for its actions against the
Herero and nama people a hundred years
after its original extermination order
japanese-americans who brought cases
during internment were later able to
prove in court that the US Solicitor
General had not followed ethical
guidelines and presenting evidence Japan
continues to be brought to the table for
resolution of the question of comfort
women in Korea and China the British
government has agreed to pay settlements
to the Mau Mau survivors it once
demonized Argentinian courts continue to
prosecute members of the hunters for
torture and murder and to work with
grandmothers of the babies stolen from
mothers who were killed Chile has spent
years bringing its generals to justice
and even Guantanamo troubling as it
remains has surrendered most of its
prisoners
mass releases in its first several years
have been followed since by more
measured departures established by
executive order in 2011 periodic review
board hearings now give prisoners the
opportunity to make a case for their
release but dozens of forever prisoners
those the government still believes are
dangerous but for whom no evidence or
only evidence tainted by torture is
available remain policy planners will
always return to mass detention because
it seems as if it should work and it
feels as if it could be done humanely
the damage done by concentration camps
has never stopped the reflexive
enthusiasm for their use as Justice
Antonin Scalia said of japanese-american
internment you are kidding yourself if
you think the same thing will not happen
again 20 miles from the Spanish border
in a canopy of emerald trees the
entrance to the camp at curse deep in
southern France seems like a path into a
dark fairy tale a single narrow road
lined with identical stelae on each side
leads into the camp but it is impossible
to see through the trees where it goes
curse is large the road through its
middle extends 2/3 of a mile or more
though most of it has fallen to ruin
amid the trees and undergrowth that have
been allowed to swallow much of the
former campsite small signs mark where
building stood and walking past marker
after marker for another island of
barracks that has gone to ghost it is
strange to think of the world filled
with these cities of death many
permanent Nazi camps were even larger
great metropolis and closed universes
here a machine shop in this corner the
rabbit hutches in the uniform factory
along that path whole warehouses for the
clothing of the murdered over there a
crematorium at several camps buildings
for detainees were burned shortly after
liberation because of unburied corpses
and the risk of disease at others such
as Treblinka everything was destroyed by
the retreating Nazis in an attempt to
hide their crimes buildings raised train
tracks taken up earth ploughed and sand
from a nearby quarry used to cover what
was left
at the death camp of Auschwitz Birkenau
however the shoddy barracks deteriorated
on their own slowly collapsing to ruin
today a reconstruction of the foundation
of crematorium 4 which was set on fire
by prisoners during an uprising now sits
open to the elements uneven piles of
bricks scattered like broken teeth
across the earth everywhere on
tombstones in the jewish cemetery occurs
along the cracked bricks of beer canal
amid dirt and debris little piles of
stone rise tiny memorials to the dead at
no and Gama in northern Germany where
gypsy boxer Johann trollman labored
before he was murdered
a hush prevails most of the original
buildings for prisoners have been
leveled little more than their
foundations remaining the long
rectangular shapes stretching on and on
resembled the graveyard for an
institution but one that refuses to stay
dead
in California and at other
japanese-american internment sites the
thousands of barracks are gone after the
war ended and the camps at tule Lake
closed the long houses that held
families were split in half loaded onto
an improvised flatbed trailer and hauled
off by homesteaders today some remain
outside town with one still in use as a
storage shed by a farmer its interior
lined with Japanese graffiti scribbled
up and down the walls leaving Guantanamo
on a clear day it is possible to see
much of the naval base from above as the
plane climbs in banks north the
landmarks that visitors are forbidden
from photographing for security reasons
grow small and indistinct the tents of
Camp Justice blur with the media hangar
and the courtroom complex the detention
sites fade from view rising higher the
plane arcs over open water leaving
behind the base and then the island
altogether along with the vanished
remains of the first Cuban concentration
camps from a century before half a world
away said the burned-out villages of the
row Hanja the camps of north korea and
black sites for systems yet to be
discovered the last moment in time when
no concentration camp existed was more
than a century ago that moment seems
unlikely to come again
the face of the planet is riddled with
camps and the ruins of camps even from
the Vantage of outer space it is still
impossible to take it all in there is
always a location out of view on the far
side of the globe or the innocent and
the guilty and those in between have
been trapped together for a time for now
or forever old camps reopen new ones are
born no final chapter can be written yet
for the chronic spectacle of the camps
so that's my attempt to cover six
continents in a hundred years but I'm
happy to take questions because
obviously this is just a skittering
across the surface here are there any
questions
oh she's gonna go she's gonna bring mic
to you hi I loved your reading and I'm
very curious about your definition of
concentration camp and whether the
people within the concentration camp
scene have to seem to be seen as the
enemies or Inlet in Latin America you
see this and I guess it'd be true in
Vietnam where you take a whole bunch of
people out and you put them in a village
over there so that they're not providing
materials to guerillas there's no
there's no torture there's no coercion
you're getting them out of the way
do you consider those concentration
camps and do you deal with them in your
book I do because those are actually
what those first Cuban camps were like
they just pushed all the Cuban peasants
out of the countryside and so that
anybody who was left they were allowed
to shoot and so anybody who's stayed
would be shot and what they wanted was
to keep them from supplying food and
arms so the situation you're talking
about is actually I would say probably
across history the most common situation
and that's an important thing to realize
because this is also true for different
reasons of the row hinge oh I don't
think in the case you're talking about
and I also don't think originally in the
situation with the row hinge when they
were first put into detention camps
after the riots in 2012 I don't think
the intention was to kill them
things are looking much grimmer now I
mean that we have all the elements of
what appears to be an ethnic cleansing
going on either we have to wait for the
Human Rights Watch and the UN to finish
reports and stuff but what we're
watching in progress is quite disturbing
but in both those cases and in many
other cases with camps the mere act of
moving a tremendous number of people and
enclosing them in a different space or
forbidding them from coming back often
is done or sanitation is difficult where
food access can be hard
where there if the insurgency steps up
then the first people who aren't going
to get food they're not going to be your
troops they're going to be those people
over there that you've labeled the enemy
so there's a varying number of outcomes
I would say the best outcomes have
typically been in World War one where
internment was sort of professionalized
very few people died in those camps now
there were some that were along the
battle lines that were very dangerous
because that the towns would be
surrounded and then when the French
would take back over they wanted to know
who had collaborated with the Germans
and when the Germans would take back
over they would want to so lots of
people were getting shot in those
instances but in the actual camps in
Berlin and London around the globe most
people who went and came out and I think
that's a really important part to
understand a piece of also why'd the
Nazi camps were not paid more attention
to they were covered in the journals and
in newspapers and New York Times The
Times of London they were described in
terrible terms but I think that there
was still this idea that had reigned in
World War one that these people would do
their time in a difficult moment of
instability and then they would be let
they would let out at some point so
people went in volunteer they were told
to report they reported because they had
all seen it before so I do count anytime
you take a group of people make them go
somewhere else and then detain them is a
concentration camp so so we're talking
transit camps labor camps internment
camps death camps I'm trying to rather
than just see the Nazi if we look back
from today the Nazi example looms over
everything but if we go back to the very
beginning and see how the phrase emerged
and what it's meant over time I want to
sort of bring that definition back
because we're much less likely to face
gas chambers at Auschwitz
we're much more likely to face a
situation like we have with the Roja
today or something that was meant as a
detention that was segregation but sort
of quell riots and violence that was
happening then if you don't wrap it up
if you don't reintegrate those people
they are labeled the enemy and it turns
into something much more dangerous and
there are instances where what you've
talked about also turned into dangerous
things but sometimes it's just a matter
of starvation and sometimes it's just a
matter of unjust detention so there's a
whole range of things that happen in
these camps there another question yes
so first of all I love your prose I
can't wait to read the book I have
multiple copies you'll have to sign them
all my apologies but I'd like to pull on
this thread about the definition a
little bit more because I find that I
have a mental image of this and my
mental image included Andersonville
during the Civil War though maybe that
doesn't qualify because it's a camp for
enemy combatants so I was taking notes
about sort of what are the defining
features misery seems to be the common
courtesy currency so that's definitely
the case mass detention of civilians
without trial the use of torture
re-education through labor though that
term seems to be absent from some of the
examples so is that a concept that
changes with time or does it just depend
upon where it is it evolves and that's
part of what I was trying to get across
in the book too is each chapter so many
things I could have covered and I didn't
because they asked me for a hundred
thousand word book and I turned in 150
thousand word book and I really thought
I probably shouldn't push my like any
more than I did so there there's only
two paragraphs on the Balkans
for instance which could have been five
books all by itself
the re-education through labor is a
later development and that comes kind of
from the Soviet model and then it
becomes part of part and parcel of what
you see in a lot of communist nations
like post-revolution Vietnam you know
has the re-education aspects to it you
have China certainly adopted that and
expanded in its own way so there's this
combination of external things and local
characteristics but each chapter deals
with kind of a new evolution I went from
when that term first emerged and so
that's where the book starts but in the
introduction you'll be happy
Andersonville and I mentioned the
Spanish mission system and Native
American reservations because those are
all the closest precursors not just
geographically and in time but there are
most kin to those things I Andersonville
I would exempt a little because I tried
to stay away from POWs camps because the
book was still this long even without
addressing POWs camps but there are
times where civilians and POWs are mixed
and there's a couple places in the book
where I address that when it's not clear
and I would put bontona mo is one of
those not so much POWs but we wouldn't
say what their status was I don't know
if you remember that after 9/11 when
people started being brought to
Guantanamo in early 2002 it's like are
they enemy combatants are they and we
wouldn't say what protections they had
that's why we didn't want to say because
we want to be able to question them to
stop the next 9/11 from happening and if
we locked them down with giving them the
name then they would fall under Geneva
Conventions and we would be bound to
certain things so that's one of those
situations where it's mushy
Andersonville I think was POWs but that
kind of enclosure is exactly what Oh
would otherwise fit the reason I also
started not just when the phrase begins
but in that moment in time in 1896 is
because there's also a role that
technology plays that's very important
barbed wire was mass-produced in the
1870s and patented in the 1870s so it
existed before then but it really came
into high production then so I don't
think it's an accident that not very
long after that you have the first
opportunity that's because it Tran it
really transforms warfare you can't run
a bunch of horses at a wall of barbed
wire you know you can't so right away
military strategists you're using it
different ways and one of the things
that they can use it for is you don't
need as many people if you remember the
general in the first section I read was
saying it's gonna take a lot of people
to hold these people well it turns out
if you order a whole bunch of barbed
wire from all of her brothers in
Pittsburgh which is what the next guy
did you don't have to have that many
people you don't have to have as many
people you have automatic weapons as
well is the other invention that makes
it possible to have a small guard force
holding a large number of people in a
fixed setting automatic weapons didn't
play so much of a role in the
spanish-american war in terms of the
camps but very soon after that evolves
to be something that you have with the
camps that's what the guards have so
it's amorphous - it's like when is it a
refugee camp when does it turn into an
internment camp when does it you know
want anima was first a refugee camp
you know we had Haitians there and there
were I think twenty three thousand at
one point I might have the number
slightly wrong it was a huge number of
people fleeing political instability at
home that we didn't want to let on to
the US mainland and so we held them
there and that saves them from drowning
at sea certainly so there's a refugee
camp angle to that but what I found
often is if you hold a lot of people for
a long time a place kind of gets
acclimated to it and so then it was a
few years later that courts actually
intervened to force the release of
hiv-positive Haitians because they
weren't getting medical care or access
to lawyers so then we moved from a
refugee camp thing to something that's a
little more disturbing and all this was
known when we chose Guantanamo and in
fact when I think it was Rumsfeld at the
first press conference announcing this
is what we were going to use when a
reporter asked why would you use it
every time we've used it it's been awful
awful things have happened and he says
well it's the least worst place and
that's what that's literally the quote
there's a book that's called like the
least worst place because we wanted you
know we the American government is I'm
really speaking for that one wanted to
be able to detain these people and
interrogate them and we needed to do it
outside constitutional protections but
inside a place that was under American
control and so one the very way it was
chosen it was extra legal I think so
that's a long answer to a short question
are there other questions yes this is
great I have a question about some
institutions that may fall within your
analysis or if they fell out what
curious about why they fell maybe it was
cuz I didn't have room but please
because they didn't have room but so
slavery and the American plantation
system or in the extermination slavery
variety that you find the Caribbean both
strike me as origin stories of
concentration camps the word isn't being
you
then but you know you analyzing the word
or the thing I'm alright with the idea
but that's a really wonderful question I
address it briefly in here because I
distinguish the two not by competitive
levels of horror because I think
probably together they represent like
the absolute worst of what humanity is
capable of but for the transatlantic
slave trade
I suggest that the economics of it were
what drove that so the the detention was
an outcome of the economic model whereas
the detention is the leading thing in
the concentration camps but certainly
there are physical spaces you could go
to and look at side by side that might
be indistinguishable so I don't want to
relativize that by saying it's somehow a
lesser thing I just in the book I
mentioned and separate it out that
economics was what was driving slavery
and this impulse to detention which is
what I was trying to explore with the
book why would you the locking up part
why would you do that so I do separate
it out because I'm wondering about
segregation
1896 it's the beginning of separate but
equal with Plessy versus Ferguson and
that also strikes me as a concentration
camp you use the word and it's for you
the concentration camp includes things
that kind of the atomized concentration
camp deliberate attempt to hide so
that's the atomization and combined with
the clandestine nature of it for me
because that comes later as an outgrowth
of not being able to detain people
publicly in barracks with big because
that's after the Nazi thing in the West
at least that's seen as not permissible
but there's a whole list of things that
I go into from African American rates of
imprisonment to yeah at present seems to
be a pretty and people thought all the
time like higher rates of incarceration
than under Stalin I mean I think those
are all really legitimate things and
you'll see there's like a two paragraph
section where I list all the things that
regretfully like I can't fit in the book
but that they desert that they are
related phenomena and that they deserve
their own like
look at in this context and everything
you just listed is in that section and
there's some more too so I don't want to
dismiss that at all but it is literally
there was a question of putting some
kind of boundaries around but they are
all related there's no doubt about it
I mean and they play into each other in
some interesting and terrifying ways
after the Tulsa race riots so white
extremists I think we'd have to call
them white supremacist burned down a
middle-class basically was called I
think black Wall Street in Tulsa and the
response was to take all that
african-americans and put them in what
was called in the newspapers at the time
a concentration camp so instead of
focusing on the white people who had
burned the place down they took all the
African Americans and put them in a camp
and they wouldn't let them go until a
white person came to vouch for them and
the newspapers report this at the time
with no sense of irony at all just
almost whimsically is too strong of a
word
but many of the white people that came
to get people out of that camp only knew
the nickname of their servants or only
knew their first names and so it became
very difficult to get people out because
there might be 50 people answering to
that and so is this sort of horrific
look back at this moment but it was in
the newspapers at the time it was
described as a concentration camp so the
phenomena are certainly related yes
she's got the money here Oh Paul jaws
for chuckling when you ask if there are
any questions because this book is sort
of sort of stimulate a lot of questions
I hope so
I would think also I post are laughing
when I read about the American citizens
in these Japanese internment camps of
which there were two thirds out that
number is correct yes word yes we kept
records on that but I really got a
chuckle out of when they said the
American citizens which was two thirds
of them got notified that they had to go
about absentee ballots on
oh you already read the book huh you
already read that section oh very good
yes they get there in the camp they're
put in the camp and they get
notification on how to vote in the next
election you'll see it's in the book
there's a section yes how you can get
your absentee ballots so that you can
vote from your detention camp exactly
but they called them war relocation
centers they were very careful to try to
even though everybody at first called
them concentration camps because they
didn't know about death camps yet but
they were also the government called
them war relocation centers ludicrous if
you're her abilities on God's bridge
what if all the Nazis as the Jews would
they like to participate actually that's
one thing that might surprise you in
1933 when the first concentration camps
were formed they rounded up a lot it was
a lot of Communists at first that were
rounded up the very first waves they
were taken the first camp that's in my
book is they're held at Nora and in this
first tiny camp at Nora they take them
to vote so they actually took them to
vote which resulted in this amazing
spike in the Communist ballot in that
little town because there weren't any
communist hardly in that town but they
took the prisoners to vote so then
suddenly all the ballots for this you
know because it was the prisoners from
the camp so you'd be surprised there are
more parallels than you might expect a
prisoners in a lot of systems you heard
in Auschwitz were allowed to receive not
in the death camp but in the main
Auschwitz camp were allowed to receive
packages prisoners in Chile and
Argentina sometimes had family visits
one woman I interviewed said you'd think
they'd let you see your family you'd
think that would mean that you're going
to live but no they might kill you just
the same so there's a weird mix of
trying to make things look better and
keep society thinking that these camps
are something else with Horrors going on
so there might be more parallels and you
think but I'm not saying that
japanese-american internment camps were
Nazi death camps I'm not making that
comparison at all tragedy by old
standards certainly and this is an
attempt to lay out all the various
tragedies but in your head sort of heard
you talked about in the Vietnam when
they try to concentrate civilians so
they wouldn't help the military with
food and supplies of what have you the
analogy I saw there was in South Africa
when the British put the women and
children of the Boer soldiers right
yeah the British claim that they were
doing it for humanitarian and military
reasons because these civilian women and
children were supplying the Boers at
night and the British but they also said
they were going to protect them from
black Africans that would harm them out
on the veldt so there's always there's
always been a combination of trying to
sell it as a civilizing thing as because
they were teaching the Boer children
English was part of their reason for
putting them in these camps a
humanitarian reason and a punitive
military there's there's usually like a
braided number of things going on in any
camp system but you see the same kind of
themes rise again and again
is I know there's other people with
questions did you want to ask anything
else okay perfect now there are other
questions where you take the parallels
of current like incarcerated a lot of
people the American Indian situation
that tells the situation and do a deep
dive and then compared to the past
possible I think I this was really I
went to four continents and I'm still in
touch with people who are in the rojan J
camps who we don't know what's going to
happen to them I'm still able to
communicate with them it's a little
overwhelming so I think I'm gonna write
my next book about I'll still be writing
pieces about this book like journalistic
pieces magazine stories I think I need a
break before I do the next one but but I
do plan to do a second book on detention
because I feel there's so many other
things that haven't been addressed in
the u.s. your definition was where
they're doing it outside the law I'm
trying to bring it in the law our
incarceration is inside the law and I
talked about that when a system is sort
of choking on itself and I think that is
a danger sign it can also be a sign of
health when it's choking on itself that
there's some remedies that are still
available to allow it to choke but but
yes that idea of legal detentions is
something I might look at in a future
book because I think it definitely needs
one I think the issue of border
detentions there's a number of things
that are happening like right this
moment in the US are there other
questions
thank you very much for hanging out I'm
happy to sign here's a look at some
books being published this week Pulitzer
prize-winning biographer Ron chernow
explores the life of President ulysses s
grant in billionaire at the barricades
Fox News Laura Ingraham weighs in on
president Trump's political agenda and
his relationship with the Republican
Party
Emmy winning actor Ed Asner shares his
thoughts on the Constitution and today's
social and political issues in the
grouchy historian raising Trump provides
an inside look at how Ivana Trump raised
the president's eldest three children
Donald Jr Eric and Ivanka Pulitzer Prize
winning author and Applebaum argues that
the Soviet Union killed over three
million Ukrainians from 1931 to 1933 in
red famine also being published this
week Harvard University's sir heap Loki
looks at the history of Russian
leadership in lost Kingdom in spy
schools Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist Daniel Goldin reports on how
national security agencies established
espionage rings at American universities
code girls profiles a secret team of
female code breakers during World War
two by former Washington Post reporter
Liza Mundy
Roger Hodge deputy editor of the
intercept shares his family history of
ranching in Texas blood and journalist
Kenneth White recalls the life of
President Herbert Hoover look for these
titles in bookstores this coming week
and watch for many of the authors in the
near future on book TV on c-span too
malee and many Osage campaigned for
justice to pursue the killers but
because of prejudice the white
authorities often neglected these crimes
because the victims were Native
Americans
what's more and one of the things that
shocked me was how corrupt much of the
justice system was how lawless this
country still was back in the 1920s
especially in this remnant of the
frontier many lawmen had very little
training
it was often easy if you were powerful
to buy off a lawman Molly and other
Osage turned to private investigators
private investigators actually had a
much larger prominent role in sis in
society back then because they often had
to fill this void but the problem with
private investigators were they often
had criminal backgrounds they often were
available to the highest bidders the
boundaries between a good man and a bad
man were extremely porous and many of
the private investigators who were
working this case seemed to be
concealing evidence rather than an
earthing it and while this was going on
it wasn't only Molly's family that was
being systematically targeted other
Osage were dying - there was a champion
steer Roper who got a call one day and
he left his house and when he came back
he dropped dead frothing at the mouth
evidence will later indicate that he too
had been poisoned most likely was
strychnine and for those of you familiar
with Agatha Christie mysteries you know
the strychnine is just an absolutely
awful poison it causes the whole body to
convulse as if with electricity and you
slowly suffocate while you're conscious
until you mercifully die one of the
reasons poisoning was so common such a
common way back then to kill the Osage
is because even though scientists knew
how to detect poisons the local lawmen
wouldn't perform toxicology's so you
could simply go to the app of the local
drug store or the or the
shoe store pick up some form of poison
and give it to somebody or spiked liquor
or and it was an easy way to kill
somebody and be undetected and by 1923
other people who had also were trying to
catch the killers were also being killed
there was one man a lawyer who started
to gather evidence and one day he
received a call from an Osage who was
dying of poisoning in Oklahoma City he
took the train there he told his wife
before he left he had ten children that
I've got evidence in this hiding spot if
anything happens to me make sure you get
it and give it to the authorities he
then went to Oklahoma City he met with
the so sage he gathered evidence after
the Osage had died of the poisoning he
called local authorities he says I have
enough evidence to catch the killers I'm
coming back to Osage County I'm getting
on the next train but when the train
arrived he wasn't there he didn't get
off and they sent out the bloodhounds
looking for him there were local Boy
Scout troops in the area that took up
the search and he was eventually found
his body lying by the railroad tracks
somebody had thrown him from the train
when his wife then went to the hiding
spot somebody had already gotten there
and cleaned out all the evidence as well
as the money that he had left for her
and the ten children who were left
destitute many of the children were then
raised by Osage families there was
another man an oil man who was a friend
of the Osage and he went to Washington
DC to hopefully get federal authorities
to investigate these cases especially
given the local corruption and he got to
a boarding house in the Capitol he
checked in he received a telegram from
an associate in Oklahoma that said be
careful the oilman carried with him a
Bible and a pistol that evening he left
the boarding house he was abducted at
some point somebody wrapped a burlap
sack around his head
he was found the next morning in a
culvert he had been beaten to death and
stabbed more than 20 times the
Washington Post at the time said in a
headline what the Osage had long already
knew a conspiracy to kill rich Indians
finally in 1923 after an official death
toll more than 24 Osage the Osage tribal
council issued a resolution pleading and
demanding for federal authorities
untainted by corruption to intervene and
it was then that the case was taken up
by a rather obscure branch the Justice
Department one that certainly will not
seem very obscure on this day in
particular it was then known as the
Bureau of Investigation and it would
later be renamed the FBI and I think
it's somewhat fitting to the stage to
talk a little bit about the bureau
because I think it's probably in a lot
of people's minds and the Bureau back
then was really a ragtag operation it
had only a smattering of agents they
were not authorized to carry guns if
they wanted to arrest somebody they had
to get a local lawman to make the arrest
and they had very limited jurisdiction
over crimes but they had jurisdiction
over American Indian reservations and so
that is why the Osage murders became one
of the FBI's first major homicide cases
and in 1925 the new boss man J Edgar
Hoover summoned this man Tom white to
Washington he said he needed to see him
right away
now Tom white is also a remarkable man
and in many ways he's like Molly he
reflects and embodies the transformation
of the country he was born in a cabin in
Texas on the frontier he was from
essentially a tribe of lawmen his father
was a sheriff he grew up he saw people
being hung criminals being hung he
became a Texas Ranger
many of his brothers he practice law
riding on a horse with a pearl handle
gun at a time when justice was often
meted out with a smoking barrel of a gun
and by the 1920s when 1925 when Hoover
suddenly summons him to Washington he
has to wear a suit he's got to learn to
adapt techniques like fingerprinting
handwriting analysis would become an
important part of this case he has to
file paperwork which he can't stand and
when he gets to the bureau he doesn't
know why Coover has summoned him but
Hoover at the time was replacing many of
the old frontier lawmen with a new breed
of agent these college boys who typed
faster than they shot and the old-timers
like white would mock them as Boy Scouts
and in fact they had very little
criminal experience and so Hoover had
kept on the roles
just a few frontier lawmen like white
and they were known as the Cowboys and
this is actually a picture of Hoover
taking just a few months before white
saw him so this is exactly what Hoover
looked like and his desk he was only 29
years old at the time when he became
director he was not yet an autocratic or
had all the autocratic power that he
would have